the screen readers that you know who
have sold screenplays how much of that
work is better than some of those who've
just put it in a drawer they finished it
they've done 10 drafts but they're just
not willing to like either take what
they need to do to go out and pitch it
or no one's really looked at it and said
this is the one well you know you're
hitting on on both things that sell so
one is you talked about pitching right
and and there are some people I've seen
who do very well in their careers not
necessarily just sell something so much
as get a career off of the script that
they wrote and I've seen and it's one
breed of writer that can just make
connections with people you know
convince them first to read the thing
which is hard to do there's that kind of
writer that does very well but then
there's this other kind of writer that
does very well because you have to pass
the script along they have written
something with such a specific voice and
commitment to the characters or an idea
or to atone that it makes everybody want
to pass the script along so it's those
two things either being really good at
sort of getting your stuff out there and
getting it in front of the right eyes or
being exceptional on the page one of
those two things will get you the career
that you want charisma versus craft or
no it's not just charisma the first the
person who has charisma and craft that's
the person and I've seen a couple of
those and that's a guaranteed success
the people who do well can have just one
charisma or craft but it would be nice
if they had they had all of them
you